Putin
a year since his last address to the
nation and his first since the start of
what Russia calls special military
operation in Ukraine President Vladimir
Putin said the country will do whatever
it takes to win
he said moscow's attempts at dialogue
have only been met by hypocrisy and NATO
expansion but going to war was the fault
of the West
it was the West that started the war and
Russia is using Force to stop it the
goal of the West is unlimited power the
Special Operation was launched to
protect the Russian Federation and
eliminate the Nazi threat
security was beefed up in Moscow as
hundreds of members of Russia's
political Elite and Armed Forces
attended his state of the nation's
speech Putin announced benefits to help
people and said Russia had maintained
its economic strength in spite of
Western sanctions but outside critics
challenged the Russian president's
narrative this whole decision was based
on miscalculations by Russia he
overestimated the power of the Russian
military
he underestimated the power of the
Ukrainian military he underestimated the
result of the Western countries to stand
up against Russia
Putin accused the best of plotting to
send nuclear weapons to Ukraine before
The Invasion his wide-ranging address
was meant to assure the audience at home
and warned world powers including by
announcing the suspension of Russia's
participation in the start nuclear arms
reduction treaty with the United States
Russia is suspending participation in
start the nuclear arsenals of the UK
France as well as the U.S are directed
against the Russian Federation Moscow
will take this into account it is
unacceptable that the U.S has started to
reshape the world order only to suit
itself in the last year the zaparisia
nuclear plant in Ukraine which is the
largest in Europe has come close to
nuclear disaster
and the possibility of nuclear weapons
is being used if the war escalates has
been widely reported
acknowledging the impact of the war all
those gathered at this conference center
in Central Moscow stood in silence to
commemorate Russian service people who
died Putin announced a special fund to
assist families of soldiers and Veterans
Russia will do whatever it takes to win
the message from a defined President
Putin was to assure his people what
you're hearing from the West is untrue
according to him the West has been
unable to isolate Russia defeat its
military or break its economy but as the
war drags past the one-year Mark there
is no denying that the people are
beginning to feel the impact Moscow